everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today I'm gonna be going
over game eight from the 2013 chess
World Championships between an on the
current champion and the Challenger
Magnus Carlsen up into this point Magnus
Carlsen has a two point lead he's won
two of the games and they've pretty much
drawn the rest of the game so we have a
12 game series and going into game
number 8 Magnus Carlsen definitely
feeling like he has the advantage game
number 8 why it's gonna be played by
Magnus Carlsen and Anand and this fits
your games gonna be playing the black
pieces Magnus Carlsen starts with E 4
and then we see e5 something we've seen
very frequently in this tournaments we
see the Rui Lopes and then we see the
Berlin defense now keep in mind Magnus
Carlsen has played the Berlin defense a
few times already as black and has had
pretty good success with it and so it
looks like an on has decided that okay
well maybe there's something to playing
as black playing the Berlin defense so
decided to go ahead and play it to
himself knowing that he needs a very
strong defense from black because he
needs some points because there's only
about four games left five if you count
this one left in the series so he needs
some points on the board because
obviously he wants to reclaim this title
so after Knight to f6 Magnus Carlsen has
a few different ways to play very common
has been this pawn to d3 Magnus Carlsen
decides to go ahead and opt for the
castling and then after the knight takes
now to play this rook over here to e1
more common is just this Knight here to
d4 we saw this earlier in the tournament
but Magnus Carlsen decides to play the
rook over here to eat one and you can
tell that he's very comfortable with the
Berlin defense not only does he play it
a few times in this tournament as black
so he knows what's to think about
but in this particular game he was
making all of his moves very very
quickly wasn't even really thinking
about him and pretty much what that
means is you have all these memorized
you've gone through all these lines and
so that there's no thinking involved an
on that aside
to bring his knight back here to these
six and we see the knight capture on e5
now it is possible you know there's many
variations white could have opted for
the exchange variation here you know
after the pawn takes then we could have
the knight take here if you wanted to to
get that pawn back in material and then
you know after the bishop comes to e7
you know because there's a discovered
attack here then the king can castle on
the King side this is gonna be you know
fairly good game also black could decide
if you wanted to to castle on the Queen
side you first want to get his Bishop
out and then you know Queen here to d7 a
little bit later could also castle on
the Queen side when you have this pawn
here on c7 and c6 but Magnus Carlsen
decided to instead just go ahead and
take with this Knight right here and now
the bishops gonna come here to e7 so
both sides just kind of opening up this
efile just going to attack that then the
bishops gonna come back here to f1 again
could have decided to go ahead and take
here on c6 and then after the exchange
you know we've already kind of talked
about it definitely not going to bring
his his Bishop back here to see for most
players you know in this particular case
and the Berlin defense there's no real
reason to go ahead and give up your
bishop so Magnus Carlsen just decided to
bring that Bishop back here to f1 for
the time being we now see an on take
with his knight on e5 and the Magnus
Carlsen takes with his rook like this
has to go ahead and castle on the King
side didn't have the exchange over here
so he's gonna be a little bit tricky for
him you know to get this bishop involved
into the game get the Queen involved and
then castle on the Queen side decides to
go and take for the safer routes go
ahead and castle on the King side and
that - Carson's gonna extend a little
bit with this pawn here to d4 you know
controlling this rook in the center but
again you know just putting a lot of
pressure on the center of the board
Black's gonna have to play a few moves
before he can counter-attack with his
own pawns decides to play this you know
Bishop here to f6 which not only attacks
the rook but also counter-attacks this
pawn here on d4 the ribs are swings back
here to e1 controlling this long file
right here you know again Magnus Carlsen
has a small advantage he is controlling
you know the serve the bow over this
pawn
he does have you know his rook here on
the e-file but again it's a very slim
margin that he has as far as development
advantage now the works gonna swing over
to e8 trying to just counter-attack not
mine discretion plays pawn to c3
strengthening is his Queen side over
here getting ready to get some of his
other minor pieces involved into the
game black decides to go ahead and just
exchange a few pieces off which is
completely fine with Magnus Carlsen the
faster that he can exchange these pieces
off the board the faster he can get to
an in-game state where he's been much
stronger than the non in this particular
tournament or it just gets to a point
where he can just draw it Magnus Carlsen
at this point in the tournament he's
thinking hey Charles are fine I'll just
draw the rest of the games I can even
drop a game if I need to that's gonna be
okay I'll still be a champion and on
however he definitely wants to go for
you know the wind so you see that
throughout this game fighting for you
know small incremental advantages and so
that's that's kind of what an odds going
for now the Knights gonna swing back
here to e8 kind of position himself a
little bit better the bishop is gonna
come out again both sides just trying to
get all of their pieces involved into
the game and trying to put them in a
better spot so that's what we see you
actually see kind of a mirror over here
on the Queen side so after you know the
bishop comes involved into the game we
see pawn here to do six a little bit
breathing room for this King over here
also this Bishop King moved back it's
not gonna be doing too much you know
this is kind of a blockade almost
there's no great squares for this bishop
here on f6 to really do anything
and then after Knight here to d2 bend
over there to g7 the Queen comes up
completing developer development for
Magnus Carlsen we now see an on play
this pawn to c6 so if we kind of look at
the setup here what both sides are
looking to do the Queen side not much is
going to be happening over there this
pawn structure over here pretty much
spells no action on the Queen side now
there could potentially be you know a
nice little outpost for this night here
on c5 could bring it over here to e5 if
you wanted to but that's pretty much all
the action you would really see on the
Queen side you could see some pawns
pushing forward if a lot of the pieces
stay on the board you could see some
counter-attacking later on the queenside
but for the most part these are just set
up to kind of have action on the
kingside so both sides you know an on
really wants to you know use these
outpost here on e4 on c4 he wants to
control this long efile he wants to get
his bishops involved into the game see
if he can attack over here and then
start to push the action magnus carlsen
now brings his rook over to e1 both
sides really have to control this e-file
again there's not much they can do
besides control this e-file try to find
some sort of weakness on the King side
but the Queen side is pretty much
useless for both sides so now we see the
bishop come to f5 again the last piece
that you know minor piece the
denominator Carlsen though doesn't
really care he is okay with exchanging
as many pieces as fast as possible as he
can this particular game and so that's
exactly what he does so the knight takes
we now see the knight and swinging over
here to f3 wasn't gonna do much here on
c4 or ephors you can imagine and this
really allows it to come to this outpost
that we talked about here on e5 can also
come to g5 depending on what's on the
board so a lot of different options for
that night there now the Knights gonna
swing back here to g7 a much better
Square for this night he can come to
more active squares if he needs to and
so now we see the bishop come here to e5
again my name is Carlson just wants to
continue to exchange as many pieces off
the board so now the Knights gonna swing
over here to e6 again better square for
the knight there and that magnus carlsen
just exchange his pieces again knowing
that his opponent now has just three
pieces it's going to be very difficult
for nan to actually do anything
productive in this particular game now
we're gonna see the knight come to e5
again a nice little outpost for that
night the rook is gonna swing over to e8
needs to get involved into the game this
is definitely the best square for this
rook and now white plays Knight here to
g4 very important move because it looks
like it's just attacking this Queen and
opening up the e-file which it does
those but it's also a pretty dangerous
trap move for nan because throughout
this game there's so many different ways
than then on can play and it's not gonna
be too bad but after this night
here to d4 move there's a lot of things
that a non can play that are actually
gonna be very very difficult for him to
overcome and he can potentially lose the
game because of it for example you might
see Queen here to g5 which looks a
little bit more active the the Queen was
under attack and so it's still you know
protects this pawn here or the square
here on f6 doesn't want to be too
passive and bring the Queen back but
unfortunately it does quite the opposite
because after the pawn comes here to f4
it forces this Queen to move and move in
a position where it's not gonna be that
great so it can't come here to you know
h6 because it's gonna be taken it can't
come here to h5 because then after the
knight to f6 the Queen's gonna fall so
where does it really move let's say it
moves back here to d8 now well now this
Queen can come up here to you know e
five and this is very dangerous the next
move this knight can come up here to to
f6 put a lot of pressure on the game but
because this square right here is now
protected by this pawn it's a little
different so if we come back in the
particular game and we look at it we see
that the Queen moved here to to d8 and
then we see the Queen come up here to e5
now it's very important for this night
to move back here to g7 there's no real
great square besides this you know for
this night to go to or anywhere else for
black typically move to for that matter
but after we see the knight come here
let's say to you know f6 let's say the
Queen takes that this Queen can't
recapture because the rooks gonna swing
down here to e1 and the game's gonna be
over but if we actually look at the
particular situation a little bit
different let's say that Queen had come
here to d5 and now the pond pushes
forward and now let's say this Queen
comes back here and the Queen comes up
here now this Knight comes back here to
g7 now this Knight can swing up here but
it's gonna be different because let's
say this Queen now takes here on f6 now
after the Queen takes the rook can come
down here on e 1 but now there's an
opening now the King can come here to f2
it's not going to be checkmate
and this is gonna be very bad for an
honest magnus carlsen now has this Queen
that can pretty much just go around and
gobble up pieces so very different just
because that one little move that forces
anon back give some breathing room for
this King so it was very important in
the exact game that anon doesn't try to
get too cute instead in the particular
game after this Knight comes here to g4
he immediately moves his Queen back here
to d8 so that now when the Queen comes
up he can move his knight here to d7 but
Magnus Carlsen has to be a little
careful now because he doesn't want this
rook coming down here to e1 checkmate
him because this King can't move because
of the back rank may so hopefully you
guys kind of understand some of these
these small little moves as far as you
know what white does and why how black
responds and why he doesn't do certain
things because it can change big time
based on small little moves Magnus
Carlsen decides to go ahead and take on
ei de Ghent he doesn't really have a
whole lot of options you can't really
move his Queen or this you know the
rooks gonna swing down here and back
rank mate so needs to go ahead in
exchange but again this is what Magnus
Carlsen wants to do after the exchange
that you know the rook takes here on the
eights and after the Queen then we have
the four here on f6 that we kind of
talked about and so this Queen's gonna
fall so the King comes over and captured
right here and this is just pretty much
an in game that no one can really do
anything with there's too many pawns on
the board for any of the Kings to ever
move by you know if there was another
minor piece especially at night this
would be very very good in this
particular endgame but there's just no
way for either side to kind of break
through this and so after 33 moves in
the game both sides decided to just go
ahead and shake hands and draw and move
on so through eight games Magnus Carlsen
still has a two-game advantage
what's interesting is in this particular
game Magnus Carlsen only used 20 minutes
for the entire game which is crazy
because the world championships on the
line he has two hours for the first four
team moves and he gets an additional
hour and he used all of twenty minutes
because again for the first few moves he
was just rapid-fire there was no
thinking it was all automatic
and then just got into a situation where
all the action was on one side of the
board the kingside magnus carlsen didn't
have to think too much there weren't too
many crazy variations he was pretty much
as trying to exchange as fast as
possible and he got into a situation
where an on just didn't have anything
you know looking at the game playing the
berlin defense showed that anon wanted
to try to find some advantage that his
opponent had found in the berlin defense
but Magnus Carlsen it looked like just
was was too masterful of knowing both
sides of what to do and how to find a
very very quick drawl and that's what he
did so going into game 9 again we have
four games left magnus carlsen has a
two-game lead hopefully you guys enjoyed
game eight and I'll see on the next
video thanks for watching